[Music]  to go to the bathroom right now nailed  it  raised everybody's so obsessed with  boobs aren't you guys liked it if girls  looked at your dicks all the time be  awesome  Nick's penis is comparable to that of a  baby not growing is there something  wrong with me  are we just a couple of freaks my mom  says real beauty is on the inside is  your colon not packed with crap I just  don't think boys care that we're smart  whoa  we live in a society that fixates on the  female form in a psychologically  estimating way I can't be horny and  still be a decent guy  [Music]  my girl's parents are going through a  d-box and she needs to that was  beautiful  no no I'm just trying to be normal  [Music]  my god Nick felt that Gina  we are gossiping Oh what did you just  say you're a this is vodka listen you  want me sharper what  blow me into the toilet I don't want  someone to come in here and be like you  [Music]  [Music]  you